Mary Kay Cabot Browns beat writer for
Cleveland come and a lot to write about
as of late well you always have a lot to
write about but some positive things are
we too optimistic about the Browns right
now Mary Kay you know what that remains
you can see I think it depends on how it
all comes together I mean you're pulling
together a lot of different coaches a
lot of different personalities big
personalities and then now it's a matter
of just see how it all gels on the field
what's your biggest question about this
team going into training camp I think
that's it I think it's to see you know
how could Baker Mayfield keep Odell
happy and Jarvis and researching and
neat job you know how can he with all of
these guys how hot are the Browns
locally I mean the high school motion
right here just to connect the two steps
without people wanting to talk about the
Browns here compare it to the hype
around when LeBron came back to the
Cavaliers
is there any comparison I think there is
a comparison you know that was LBJ this
is obj now some big big similarities
there between media attention it could
be a circus lq it's going to be crazy i
mean there was a lot of attention
earnest feet what Johnny Manziel was
here but this is different I think this
is even bigger because this comes along
with great expectations the expectation
level for Odell Beckham jr. should be
what this year III think that that he
should be lights out I think with Baker
Mayfield and how deadly accurate he is I
think that that he should help Odell be
even more super stuff than he has been
he should exceed his production in
previous years and there's going to be
and he'll draw a lot of extra attention
but Baker get him the ball anywhere
including pink which is what he really
wants and I think it's going to be a
show
I'm also curious about Baker's
personality in handling these egos mary
kay because you know if you're Joe
Flacco it's one thing if you're Kirk
Cousins it's one thing Baker may feel
it's not afraid to say something and you
know call out a teammate here how does
that can that be something that's really
good or could it turn out to be
something really bad well I think Baker
Mayfield if I were advising I would have
him dial it back a little bit on some of
the rhetoric I would have him calling
out a teammate the way he recently did
with Duke Johnson I wouldn't have him
doing some of the stuff that he did with
Sue Jackson I would be asking him to not
waste his energy or his breath on things
like that you've got bigger picture
tonight this team expects him to go to
ultimate Super Bowls
I think he should focus on that do you
think the Browns make the playoffs I do
I really do I think there's so much
talent on this team right now that it
would be hard to miss the playoffs
ravely gravely wrong and I don't expect
that to happen the role of this coach
never been in this situation before and
you know we've talked and you know about
these egos here so what's the biggest
question you have for Freddie kitchens
well the biggest thing for Freddie I
think is not to spread it around too
much in terms of letting all the coaches
have a say super collaboration really
wants to be a team very because he
perceived that you Jackson wasn't that
but I think he's going to realize he has
to take the bull by the horns here he's
got to make the decision it all rides on
him now and I don't think you can try
too much to let everybody have a voice
Mary Kay thank you as always we
appreciate your time Mary Kay Kevin
Browns beat writer for cleveland.com
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]